hey guys welcome to another money-making
video for this video we bought red topaz
machetes from goo boo t in Thai boy Wan
iVillage and we also sold red topaz's to
him now for this money making method
you're going to need carranza gloves the
one which are a reward for the
completing the Caramba easy Diary and
you're also going to need to have
completed jungle potion which will allow
you to deposit your items to the bank
after you have a full inventory the
kilometre gloves are going to allow you
to buy the red topaz machetes from him
for less and also sell your red topaz is
for more what you're gonna need to do is
buy a good amount of trading sticks and
red topaz off the grand exchange and
then head to the village south of brim
Haven and trade go booty you want to buy
one red topaz machete and also sell five
red topaz to him and then you simply
need to switch worlds and continue doing
this until you have a full inventory and
once you're done with that you will run
north and right click send a parcel to
on Ryan hasta and he will send your
items to the bank for you so let's find
out exactly how profitable this method
is right now alright guys our red topaz
machetes just finished selling we spent
about 1 mil on the trading sticks and
red topaz that we lost in the process
and we sold the red topaz machetes for
1.38 7 mil which means we profit about
380 K but here's the thing that was only
15 minutes guys I only did that for 15
minutes that means if you multiply that
by 4 it is well over a 1 mil per hour
money making method of the exact amount
that you guys can expect to profit in 1
hour on the screen right now the only
thing is that if a lot of people start
doing this method red topaz machetes
will probably crash and they might not
be as profitable as before so definitely
check the prices before you do this
another thing is that the tribal items
in his shop are also profitable so you
can probably speed things up and maybe
even make this a 1.5 or too many make a
method per hour by buying some of the
tribal items and sending them to your
bank this will probably also allow you
to miss
the world hopping timer by filling up
your inventory faster if the prices are
good right now for you guys I definitely
recommend you do it if you guys like
this video and want to see more like it
remember to Like subscribe and leave a
comment I love hearing your guys
feedback thanks for watching
you